thank you for coming today I want to
share my original work the language of
crisis in second place options this
worker will come together with pmu and
the taussian
we will consider the most classical
modeling option Theory single item
options in this model the seller has a
heightened to sell and he is facing and
potential operators each beta eye has a
private value for this icon and we
assume that those values we will I are
drawn from application from possibly
joint distribution team
uh in auctions better is near two
reporters their values the first item
and after that the setup the setup will
pick a winner based on the reported
values and the sun determines the
Winner's payment
to get a virus as let's take a look at a
concrete example of second price auction
with Anonymous reserve for mechanism
suppose we want to sell a artwork by
castle and suppose the seller says
reserve price of for 250 million dollars
on this artwork
other underspose there are three
potential buyers Ellis has a random
value drawn from the uniform
distribution between 1 100 million and
400 million and the supposed current
outcome value is 200 million
Bob I suppose his value is between also
a uniform distribution and the outcome
value is 300 million and supposedly also
a uniform random value and the outcome
value is 400 million
so let's say what will hold the
anonymous will serve for mechanism works
first you say probably as the highest
Builder will get that and his payment is
the maximum uh maximum between the value
of Bob and the research price why
because you say the option here first to
use the subway surface to filter the low
value balance that is uh the Alice will
be rejected by the reserve request but
also for both at the 12 actually has
have four higher value of sensor results
under so say two uh joins the wrong
second price option and try it as the
higher editor gets the item and the pace
the value of the board so his payment
will be three create a million dollars
consider a must consider another example
suppose the result price now is the
lift is the rings that brought to
350 million dollars and considers the
same outcome values of areas of
electronics that the
artwork again will go to 220 and his
payment now becomes the reserved price
350 million why because now actually is
the only person whose value is the
higher than the reserve so he will
definitely win and his payment is
exactly the reserve price
so as you can see a very natural and and
considers the last concrete example
suppose the result is now 450 uh million
dollars since item will auction year
will buy things artwork and the
no-getter between areas Bob and Charlie
will get the item
so a natural question was a several
years will suppose suppose I know the
federal distributions of Alias about
Android then I would like to
optimize my research rights to Max to
maximize my expected Revenue
and let's cancel it it turns out that
the second price option with Anonymous
research is known as the revenue optimal
option and the sector optimal option is
since I will know meritense option uh
person's auction is the restricted to
Independent values under the optimal
revenues are characterized by social
values that is you can say first the
seller used the no value distributions
to determine the virtual value functions
the fact that in this way for at
repeater that
[Music]
using the reported value the option here
will calculate the virtual values of
Apple data and the winner of this option
is exactly the beta with the highest
normality for Social Security and the
payment of force a winner yes the keys
are her thresholder value for which are
keep winning
and the
it's interesting to to observe sense in
the case of ID and federal distributions
there's an option can generate exactly
to a second price option with Anonymous
research but in practice
American Auction is much more
complicated hitter and
less used in the impacted second price
option with Anonymous waste
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oracle access to the underlying
distribution key and a natural question
first started by call on the Rock Garden
in 2014.
yes the example complexity of options
that is we are supposed we have is
uncoasted who sells the fact a tools is
the federal distribution key and our
work our task is to design our algorithm
using those samples two out to obtain an
option and the sixth option should a
generator as
uh Fair according of Revenue that is
suppose in the case of Romans auction
our outcome option A showed a tree for
our apps to approximate uh connection to
the optimal Revenue uh that is the
easier multiplication for uh
guarantee of one minus Epsilon to the
optimal
revenue from the actual Federal
distributions or active Adkins forever
with the band with respect to the
optimal values
outside yes in the case of Merit option
we need to learn uh almost approximately
optimal virtual value functions and in
the case of for second price option
which is anonymous to itself since the
also uh design assignable part of forces
of such auctions is just as a reserve
price so learning nearly optimal option
exactly means learning a nearly optimal
but still Priceless so our task again is
to get a multiplicative one manner is
the Epsilon approximation to the revenue
the optimal Revenue our attitude for
Revenue loss of absolute
foreign
interesting we actually need some
assumption on the distributions uh why
because without any distribution or
function uh this problem uh will
decrease or has not is is meaningless
such as any algorithmeter has a
unbounded sample complexity uh in
standard four canonical distributional
functions uh has have been made in the
literature first is what zero one
pancreas supports the value of the
federal distributions and the forces
that we often consider LTS for arrow for
Revenue maximization the second setting
is uh yes that's the federal
distribution are supported
between an interval of one between one
and uh February very large value of edge
for these two abundance of order
settings that we can either consider
independent uh value distributions or
correlated values but notice that only
for independent values there's no option
uh Revenue optimal the third under the
fourth uh settings are about the regular
distributions and the mhr distributions
these are two technical assumptions
about single dimensional value
distribution under usage because of this
NH rep course regular and nhr are
restricted to Independent single
dimensional distributions for in these
two settings we implicitly assume that
as the federal distributions are are
actually independent
there are hundreds of works on Earth the
sample complexity and also aspects of
Revenue maximization
in this top on this topic
uh okay let me give a summary of uh for
previous work about the sample
complexity of merits and options uh C is
a long line of Works starting stays
exactly studies is the problem and so
some nearly tied a simple complexity was
finally a set holder in the worker by
about
in 2019.
uh in particular say proof sets in the
first bunker support setting so sample
complexity is uh
in every in every setting so nearly had
a sample capacity has uh almost a nearly
billion dependence on Earth the number
of bidders and a polynomial dependence
on App Store the approximation uh Arrow
and in our worker we train a way if we
adopted the technical framework by uh in
this uh advisor walkabyte or one and two
stagnar plus auction waste Anonymous
reserve and often so yeah again options
nearly take the sample complexity in
each of these four seconds uh it's
interesting to notice that the
says the title complexity sample
complexity has no dependence on the
number of operators and about under the
dependence
um
absolutely approximation arrow is
exactly the same in every section as the
Merit option
another interesting thing is that we by
we we notice that in the two angular
support that is we just note our
algorithm and our sample complexity
results does not require the federal
distributions to be independent such as
even for correlated of value
distributions the same sample complexity
is still holding but the fourth two for
the regular setting and the mhr setting
because the regularity and the mhr uh
distributional assumption issue itself
will assume more independent values so
for these two seconds we can our
algorithms adjust the block for
independent valency
uh I must also I need to mention that
our algorithms that uh in our work we
trust the pool Force the matching
outbounder that uh that is the way it
gave uh algorithm and the way proposal
uh sub managing up up on the sample
complexity as the social resource uh in
contrast this uh measuring lower bonds
are obtained in the in these two
previous works
okay uh next let me give you a high
level description of our algorithm uh
first the record setup our algorithm has
has sample access to the other line
value distribution T and the post away
in total we have for M and make some
host an indexed by K from one two three
and two n
our algorithm runs in three steps first
uh using the using those samples when
Trust
now we trust the pick the highest value
and the second the second the highest
value from from each sample and we use
this those the first order samples and
the second order samples to to build to
construct the empirical first order and
the second order cdfs
next we use these two empirical cdfs to
construct the dominated empirical cdfs
that and the important parts also the
point of this construction is that you
state that is the two extremes our
forces steadyf I mean what cityf so yes
close to Seattle R1 so we are more
careful and the way it trusted Traders
empirical distribution pair there is
most amounts but as a mid path of every
CDF we can be more broader and we can
trigger a larger part of the state DF
the information of behind stays the
dominated this dominated empirical cdfs
is that will you say the empirical the
original empirical cdfs are uh
on base the estimation of the actual
fatal distribution
as an actual first order CDF and the
second order CDF and the by streetism by
a small amount
recyclability the dominated empirical
cpfs are again it's definitely dominated
by some that's a empirical distributions
and with high probability they are also
dominated by the underlying value actual
value distributions but because the way
it was the shredder each of them by a
various movement so the dominated the
empirical ctfs are very close to the
actual city apps and the actual value
distribution
so first step of our operation algories
in your structure will we use the
dominated empirical cdfs in place
instead of the actual value distribution
anyway simply Returns the optimal
reserved with respect to the dominated
empirical distribution
since the algorithmic Paradigm is the
same as the framework by guo Wong and
the trump in 2019. in particular the uh
these points worker designs such an
algorithm for marriage option and our
our main contribution is to show that
says the framework also works for second
price auction with Anonymous WordPress
Anonymous research I mean it works not
only for individual distributions at one
F2 until FM as the four Marathon options
but I actually also workers for some
sketch or Force distribution I mean in
our case the the first the first order
and the second order cdfs are actually
the sketch so so some sketch of the
actual samples
another interesting is the thing is that
we show that as their framework actually
uh goes beyond independent settings of
independent value explosions and we
actually in the two bounded support
settings our example complexity of our
algorithm uh codes even for correlation
of value distributions
okay to uh Sun
so now we need to look at to analyze how
many samples are needed to our algorithm
to get a good Revenue guarantee so add
us analysis takes the two steps and the
second first step relies on the revenue
monotonicity property also our our map
our options on our Anonymous result for
option requested a second applies the
option with Anonymous reserve the
outcome has two possibilities first CR
is CIA and first
uh suppose serious say yes exactly one
better whose value is is the higher
sensor with the price that in this case
the outcome revenue of our auction is
exactly the result of price
and in the second case the CR at least
two or even more uh Builders whose
values all are above the result price
and we our option is exactly the same as
the Techno price option answer outcome
Revenue will be the second highest value
so we can rewrite as the outcome as a
random outcome Revenue in this formula
and after rearranging writing attention
CS4 and by taking the expectations we
can rewrite as expected Revenue in this
uh in this formula in terms of first
order the actual first order better
solution under the second order value
distribution for every possible research
uh it's interesting to it's it's easy to
say that you say suppose a statistical
dominance in terms of value
distributions implies Revenue uh Revenue
monotonicity I mean suppose we are given
two groups of distributions the first
group is first order and the second
order uh cdfs are dominates the second
group of CTX stands expected revenue
from this first group will be higher
than the second group Revenue
also another interesting observation is
that the expected direct news
uh it's it suffer it has the two terms
it's the first term trust the realized
on the first order cpf and the second
term trust the realized answer second
order say yes but notice but under I
mean uh this is exactly it's a linear
linearity of expectation and this is
generated is exactly the reason why our
algorithm can work even for
correlational distributions because the
correlation
and the first and second order cdfs can
correlate can be corrected in a even
more complicated way but when we talk
about the expected retinals CA is
nothing to do about with those such a
correlation
uh the second part of our analysis is
the results are
released will use
intermediate object I mean the step
double a three data set yes is
constructed in the following way I must
emphasize that it relies the trust is
constructed from the actual value
distribution rather than the empirical
distribution
uh in the following way and the largest
organizations unlike uh the dominated
empirical cdfs which is uh shaded in
this way or we trained us uh
double
distributed by Earth
intuitively twice as much
uh why why do we need us is the
construction because it's greatly
simplifies our analysis
you say the actual empirical CDF is a
dumbest estimation of the actual value
distribution and with high probability L
with with high probability
it's a dominated empirical distribution
by trading one unit of distance is is
dominated between a dominated by the
actual actual uh virus distributions but
since the way uh Traders the
troubleshooted cdfs are straight from
are constructed from the actual
distributions by shooting twice as much
for his high probability is uh
uh uh it's an empirical distribution is
dominated as actual distributions but uh
Dom itself dominates the double shaded
acidity apps and the using this is the
statistic dominance together with the
munching the revenue monotonicity we can
obtain the following three or four
equations and uh so first uh equip the
first inequality simply says that simply
applies says the revenue monopolicity
the sector in qualitatively used the
optimality of our usage our resource is
the optimal result for Waste respect to
the octopus dominated empirical
distribution so uh the second inequality
drug simply use this effect and the so
the third inequality simply again use
revenue revenue dominance I mean the
factors that is straight at the
empirical distribution dominates the
double digit apps
and
what a way
we need the only remaining step is to
show that even the revenue from wd300
cdfs it's it's close enough to close our
actual uh to the actual Revenue
uh
uh to be processed first you say by
introducing this dominated CTF it's
incurs no loss of generality because you
say with no sales and so what's the case
uh the empirical discussion can be trust
as uh double-shaded cdfs and you say
it's uh we only uh strict amount of our
streaming scheme is the trusted twice as
much as before and the intuitively you
can imagine States it was the inquiry
increases sample complexity uh twice and
the tips is the same sympathically it's
the same sample complexity but the
others is the established with the CDF
is much more convenient than the
empirical distribution to analyze
because it's fixed the CDF but as an
empirical distributions are random
objects for like answers set a rely on
the samples
under
so our remaining task is to show that
even says even the optimal revenue from
nurses W3 to the CDF is closed enough to
the optimal revenue from the underlying
actual battle discussion and the forces
step up we will use a bunch of photos of
extreme value theorems and tailor bonds
for regular and MSR distributions
uh so previously such such tools are
developed in the in the topic called the
simple versus optimal of the mechanisms
that are onset mechanisms about it too
for approximation ratios also simple
mechanism with respect to in terms of
Revenue with respect to Optimal revenues
and in our work we extend such
techniques from simple versus optimal
mechanisms I mean
extended such techniques from showing
proving approximation ratios to
to improving
sample complexity bonds or for learning
algorithms
consider MFR distributions for example
by definition we know that a Content a
single dimensional continuous
distribution has satisfies the monotone
house the rate and all energy Insurance
it satisfies this property if under
under efu States the function should
Defender based on the variable CDF
itself is a concave function on the
support of the data distribution under
using our Focus uh you uh
this this
concavity uh and if you are familiar
with this topic you'll know that roughly
speaking mhr the properties exactly
almost means uh such uh such a
distribution f2l goes to increase the uh
no as at least as fast as exponential
expression I mean in the case of
potential distribution says the
functions usually well exactly are
linear function I mean so that is the
boundary case concave function and it's
a foreclosed sensor
um
is the increase at least at at least as
fast as exponential exposure and our uh
our extreme value CRM uh for structure
and natural distribution in the systems
not only uh shows up every individual
distribution goes to the increase as as
fast as exponential distribution product
or even the first order distribution I
mean statistration of the highest value
of food and many uh nhr random variables
such uh such uh first order and the
second order
distributions also goes to increase at
least as far as the exponential
distribution uh the basic group of idea
they had such extreme value distribution
is better geometrical interpretation of
energy explosion I mean uh uh with a
geometric interpretation of concave or
for such distribution due to it and
using such such interpretations we will
get our discrete value Industrial crms
and uh for the case of for other setting
for the
uh for the case of other settings uh
we also developed such techniques
extreme value theorems but the other
tools about uh and tail bonds for
tailbots for regular and electronic
species
that's all thank you